megan fox and machine gun kelly are
getting candid about their sex life he
was like you're going to be naked
tonight and i was like whatever you say
daddy whatever daddy says the couple
graces the cover for british gq's autumn
winner 2021 issue making it their first
photo shoot together and boy are the
photos steamy but what's even steamier
the captions they posted on instagram
while sharing some of the images in
megan's lengthy message she writes about
their romance which she says is a mix of
feverish obsession guns addiction
shamans lots of blood general mayhem
therapy tantric night terrors binding
rituals chakra sound baths psychedelic
hallucinations organic smoothies and the
kind of sex that would make lucifer
clutch his rosary i love it it's amazing
meanwhile mgk shared his own bold
statement writing in part quote meet me
in heaven and let's [ __ ] like demons
along with the sexy photos the pair also
opened up to gq about their relationship
the jennifer's body star told the mag
when she first met mgk she wasn't
expecting they'd have such an intense
connection she explains quote i did not
anticipate walking right into my soul
mate like that meeting him it's like
meeting your own soul's reflection i
recognized so much of myself and him and
vice versa and that locked up part of me
that i had put away it's hard to top
that one man as for mgk well he says
it's his first time being in love quote
it's like because you've been around the
world and experienced so much
you think you know everything and then
you are in the arms of your destiny and
realize i don't know yet
megan and mgk who started dating in 2020
have never been shy about showing off
their romance especially on the red
carpet which et saw firsthand at the
2021 vmas are you proud of him very
proud he's the most talented boy in the
world megan you guys look awesome we'll
be back oh
i don't know if this is family friendly
y'all
and though their relationship might look
perfect in the spotlight mgk tells gq
they have their own struggles quote it
should be light but also we go to hell
with each other it's ecstasy and agony
for sure i don't want people to think
anything's perfect with us i didn't say
it was the darkest fairy tale for no
reason and one thing megan knows well
taking life's toughest experiences and
learning from them a topic she spoke to
e.t about back in 2019 there was not one
thing that i went through that was
trying or difficult that didn't help me
to grow into a better individual a
smarter stronger more patient more kind
person i think that i manifested my
reality and it was a reflection of my
own belief systems and so i had to live
through it and work through it and
continue to grow and change my beliefs
so that my reality would change
[Music]